what percent of hello aliens evolved
from land animals as opposed to plants
or ocean
slash air organisms
by the way i did um recently
see that there's uh only ten percent of
species on earth
are in the ocean
so there's a lot more right variety on
land there is
it's interesting so why is that i don't
even i can't even intuit exactly why
that would be maybe
survival on land is harder and so you
get a lot of story that i understand is
it's about small niches so speciation
uh can be promoted by having multiple
different species so in the ocean
species are larger that is there are
more creatures in each species because
the ocean environments don't vary as
much so if you're good in one place
you're good in many other places
but you know on land and especially in
rivers rivers contain an enormous
percentage of the
kinds of species on land
you see because they vary so much
from place to place and so a species can
be good in one place and then other
species can't really compete because uh
they came from a different place where
things are different so
um
it's a remarkable fact actually that
speciation promotes evolution in the
long run that is more evolution has
happened on land because there have been
more species on land because each
species has been smaller
and that's actually a warning about
something or something called rot that
i've thought a lot about which is one of
the problems with even a world
government
which is large systems of software today
just consistently rot and decay with
time and have to be replaced and that
plausibly also is a problem for other
large systems including biological
systems legal systems regulatory systems
and
it seems like large species actually
don't evolve as effectively as small
ones do
and that's an important thing to notice
about that so and that's actually in
diff that's different from ordinary sort
of um
evolution in economies on earth in the
last few centuries say
you know on earth the more technical
evolution and economic growth happens in
larger integrated cities and nations
but in biology it's the other way around
more evolution happened in the
fragmented species
yeah it's such a nuanced discussion
because you can also push back in terms
of nations and and at least companies
it's like large companies seems to
evolve less effectively
there is something
that you know
they have more resources more um
they don't even have better resilience
when you look at the scale of
decades and centuries it seems like a
lot of large companies die
but still large economies do better like
large cities grow better than small
cities large integrated economies like
the united states or the european union
do better than small fragmented ones so
yeah
sure it's it's that that's a very
interesting long discussion but so most
the people and obviously votes on
twitter um
represent the absolute uh objective
truth of things so most but an
interesting question about oceans is
that okay remember i told you about how
most planets would last for trillions of
years yes and be later right so people
have tried to explain why life appeared
on earth by saying oh all those planets
are going to be unqualified for life
because of various problems that as
they're around smaller stars which last
longer and smaller stars have some
things like more solar flares maybe more
tidal locking
but almost all these problems with
longer-lived planets aren't problems for
ocean worlds
and though a large fraction of planets
out there are ocean worlds so if life
can appear on an ocean world then
that pretty much ensures that these
these planets that last a very long time
could have advanced life because most
you know there's a huge fraction of
ocean worlds so that's actually an open
question so when you say
sorry when you say life
you're kind of saying life and
intelligent life
so like
uh
so that's that's an open question
is land and as i suppose the question
behind
the the twitter
poll which is a grabby alien
civilization that comes to say hello
what's the chance that they
first began their early steps the
difficult steps they took
on land
what do you think
most 80 percent
uh most people on twitter think it's
very likely right what do you think i
think people are discounting ocean
worlds too much that as i think people
tend to assume that whatever we did must
be the only way it's possible and i
think people aren't giving enough credit
for other possible paths but dolphins
water world by the way people criticize
that movie i love that movie kevin
costner can do me no wrong
you